season 18 of The Voice is is chaos
because we've added a coach who's kind
of taking us all a little bit off guard
Nick Jonas has come in and he's got this
aura about him and he's kind of a quiet
guy but he's a but he's a killer and the
blinds and it completely changes the
competition into a different dynamic you
know my initial thought when I heard
that Nick was gonna be joining us as a
coach I knew he would be great at it
because I mean here's a guy who's who's
basically grown up in the spotlight and
and he's had success as a band he's had
success as a solo artist as basically
somebody who's been in the public eye at
a high level for a long time and and
that's what you that's what you look for
in a coach I think when you when you
audition for this show is somebody who's
had a ton of experience at a lot of
different things who's seen a lot of
different things that could happen in
this business and and I think he brings
probably as much experience to the table
as anybody and he's still basically just
a kid himself I don't know how they do
it this is a season 18 and the level of
talent that continues to audition for
this show they continue to come out of
the woodwork and it just blows me away
that these artists are undiscovered and
thank God they give us the chance here
you know the vibe for this season has
been it's been a lot of fun because
we're trying to figure out Nick and and
what his angle is gonna be and and
should we jump in there with him is it
is he is he beatable as a coach I mean
we're learning all this stuff you know
as we go and you'll see that in the
blind auditions and I think it makes for
a lot of fun you know Kelly's still up
to her old tricks
I think the artists who auditioned for
this show who watched the show they're
kind of on to her though she has a
little tougher time this season getting
people on her team than she's ever had
before in fact there was a day or two
she was starting to get depressed which
made me very happy and John as always I
mean I don't know what it is about that
guy he never really
has to compete that hard to get people
on his team but with Nick here he gets
humbled a few times